you ever wonder how a billionaire like
president donald j
trump pays only 750 in taxes
well on today's episode we're gonna
break down how taxes
work let's talk money
talks money on valuetainment i'm your
host adam sosnick and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode we're
going to break down the tedious
topic of taxes and make taxes
great again now i know what you're
thinking taxes oh my god you're gonna
bore me to death
but the whole goal of today's episode is
to actually make taxes
somewhat fun and palatable because who
likes paying taxes not me not you not
president trump
nobody likes paying taxes so on today's
episode we're going to explain
taxes for dummies now let me start off
by saying this the united states
tax system is complicated a f
so the whole goal of today's episode is
to break down
money and taxes in a language that you
can understand
now jumping right in you might have seen
in the news in the past few weeks
donald trump apparently has only paid
taxes for the first two years of his
presidency what
how did that happen well let me tell you
now according to new york times again
this is according to the new york times
trump avoided paying federal income tax
and this is how that happened now
whether you're a fan
or a critic of donald trump let me tell
you this there is nothing
wrong with utilizing the tax code to
one's
benefit okay let me say that again there
is nothing wrong
with utilizing the united states tax
code to one's
benefit i hope you're doing so yourself
so as an example your goal
should be to reduce your taxes and pay
as little as legally required so that's
what trump did what did trump do
he reduced his taxes by depreciating his
real estate
if you're a real estate investor you
understand the concept of depreciation
that's why real estate investors
love debt and love paying low taxes
because they depreciate
their real estate investments and they
also deduct their losses now again if
you're a fan
or you're critic of donald trump he did
have a lot of business losses and that's
how he wrote
off his losses to deduct his taxes
that's how that worked
ps he probably also hired some of the
best cpas and accountants that money can
buy
but that information is basically how
donald trump avoided paying
federal income tax now talking about
taxes let's get into the history
of taxes now taxes didn't just come up
in the last hundred years in fact
they've been here
for thousands of years in fact in
ancient mesopotamia 2500 bc
that's where taxes started now you
weren't paying money you were actually
paying livestock or different products
or fruits and vegetables
you would have to pay in taxes that's
how taxes started
2500 bc now welcome to america when did
taxes start here in america you might
have heard of something called the
boston
tea party what was the famous phrase
from the boston tea party well it was
no taxation without representation
that's how that started
then all of a sudden you had someone
called benjamin franklin who came up
with the famous quote
there are only two certainties in life
that is number one
death and number two taxes you might
heard this before i'm going to spare you
the history lesson right here
but basically it came down to this
supreme court justice oliver wendell
holmes
he's your homes he's my homes he said
taxes are what we pay
for a civilized society speaking of a
civilized society why do we all pay
taxes
what is the purpose of paying taxes i
know some people out there is like why
am i even paying taxes
well let me explain to you the
government uses taxes for the well-being
of society here are a couple different
examples
taxes collected from individuals and
corporations by the city state and
country go to the following
public safety that's cops as
firefighters respect to them to build
and repair
infrastructure you want to have streets
you want to have streets you can drive
on right you want to have
tall roads and places where you can go
that's part of taxes
agriculture to fund education to pay
for defense to pay for public
transportation for public
health we're dealing with covert right
now it's a public health crisis taxes
help
combat stuff of that disaster relief
environment
right you got funding the benefits of
government workers food and housing for
the poor and last but not least every
one of us that gets a paycheck
has a fica tax taken out of their
paycheck from their employer that's 7.65
and that goes to funding social security
and medicare
that's how that works so that is the
purpose of paying
taxes now speaking of taxes we get three
different
types of taxes tax type number one is a
regressive tax
aka a sales tax let me tell you
something about a sales tax this
typically affects
lower paid workers unproportionately let
me back up and explain
why that is so everyone has to go
grocery shopping and paying taxes
for uh shopping tolls driver's license
if you want to go get a hunting license
you have to pay
taxes you have to pay fees so let me
give you a little comparison here so
someone that makes twenty five thousand
dollars a year
versus someone that makes a hundred
thousand dollars a year twenty five
thousand
versus a hundred thousand now if someone
who makes twenty five thousand dollars
pays a thousand dollars a year
and all those types of taxes we talked
about that is four percent
of their income now versus someone who
makes a hundred thousand dollars a year
if they pay
a thousand dollars in taxes that's only
one percent
of their income so now we were talking
about this regressive tax
or sales tax that's why it affects lower
paid workers unproportionately
that is regressive tax number two the
second type of tax is a proportional tax
aka a flat tax so here's the deal with
the flat tax
this is where everyone pays the exact
same percentage
of your income so you might have heard
of someone wants to recommend a 15
flat tax like enough with elders
regressive or progressive tax
let's just pay a flat tax everyone pays
the same well in fact
nine states actually currently impose a
flat tax
on their state income and then the last
type of tax is a progressive tax
this is currently what the united states
uses for their federal
income tax that's a progressive tax
system now who does that typically
affect that actually affects
the rich who make more money the more
you make the
higher the tax bracket which we're gonna
get into so this allows lower earners
to pay very little in taxes now speaking
of taxes let's talk about
the marginal tax brackets here in
america today it's 20 20. we're going to
talk about
marginal tax brackets we're going to
throw up a little graphic on your screen
right now so you can understand what i'm
talking about
now these are the marginal tax brackets
here in america today
now there are a lot of numbers now let
me tell you something right now i'm not
going to read off every single little
number and every little detail here but
i will give you the big
picture recap on how marginal tax rates
work here in america today
so the less you make the less you'll pay
in taxes the more you'll make
in a progressive tax system the more
you'll pay in taxes
that's how that works so if you make
between zero and basically ten thousand
dollars as a single person you're only
paying
ten percent same thing so right here you
have a single on the left married on the
right there you go
so the seven different tax brackets are
seven different
buckets or brackets that you're paying
in america today depending on what you
make i'll give you those seven right now
you got 10 12 22
24 32 35
and the big dog big earner pays 37
in taxes that's if you're making over
500 000
a year in federal income so that's what
you can see on your screen right now is
the marginal tax brackets here in
america today
the more you make the more you pay now
here's the point
not everyone pays specifically 37 so
so for instance if you make 518 000 a
year
kudos respect to you you don't pay 37
flat tax right we talked about this
being a progressive tax so your first
ten thousand dollars is taxed at
ten percent your next thirty thousand
dollars to upwards of forty
you pay twelve percent then your next
amount of money you make up to about
eighty five thousand dollars you pay 22
percent
then the next amount of money you make
up to 163 000
you pay 24 upwards and onwards to 32
35 37 so the more you make you go into a
different tax bracket that's why it's
called the marginal tax bracket so
most people unless you're making under
ten thousand dollars a year are going to
be in at least
two tax brackets so again your first ten
thousand dollars if you're single
is taxed at ten percent then you move
into the twelve percent twenty two
percent
four 24 so on and so forth so again i'm
trying to not make these tax
numbers and geeky giggity giggity things
too complicated i'm trying to break them
down
but understand the more you make boom
boom
boom boom you move up into a higher tax
bracket now someone might say hold on
the more i make the more i have to pay
in taxes why would i want to make more
money
well listen my friend that's the type of
attitude that will leave you
broke and caught up in this first or
second
tax category so the more you make the
more you'll have to pay in taxes i
understand
but that's why you pay cpas and
accountants to figure out loopholes or
tax deductions
or tax benefits that you could utilize
to pay less in taxes so there's
something called
the standard deduction that you could
use or there's something called the
itemized deduction i'll let you deal
with that with your cpa
just understand that there's something
called the standard deduction that's 12
400 for an individual and that's 24 800
for a married couple or if you don't
want to choose that you can use an
itemized deduction
now we're going to go over a couple key
facts and key terms that you should
understand when it comes
to taxes first and foremost according to
the tax policy center
as many as 45 percent of tax filers
pay no federal income tax it's a crazy
number
federal income tax that is the largest
source of revenue
for the government that's how they get
their money to pay for everything
last but not least the average income
tax refund was a little over
100 now here are a couple key terms you
might want to know when speaking
with your accountant so you just
understand the name of the game when it
comes
to taxes number one a tax break a tax
break is a deduction
exemption or credit that reduces your
taxes
a tax benefit is a savings for a
taxpayer
that reduces your taxes a tax bracket
which we covered earlier right here boom
tax bracket
that's the rate at which your tax which
we talked about 10 12 22 24 32
and so on and so forth marginal tax rate
that's exactly what we just covered
right there
that's the rate you pay on an additional
dollar of income
the more you make most people are in
more than one
marginal tax bracket hopefully you're
above one tax bracket moving along we
got the effective tax rate that's the
actual
percent of your income that you pay in
taxes
tax deductible interest that's the
borrowing expense you can claim to
reduce
taxable income i.e your mortgage
interest
or student loan payment then you got agi
that stands for your adjusted
gross income which is basically your
gross income minus your adjustments
to income and then last but not least
you got a w-2 versus the 1099
so more than likely you're either a w-2
aka an employee
or a 1099 an independent contractor when
it comes
to income so that's it that's tax facts
and key terms that you should understand
moving right along let's talk about the
robert kiyosaki cash
flow quadrant we'll move real quick with
this but there's something called the
esbi
there's four levels of making money the
four levels of income four levels of
taxation
number one is an employee basically you
work you're an employee you get paid for
your time
and the amount of work determines your
income this is the basic
level of getting taxed you have no
control over your taxes you get your w-2
that's how you work then you're
self-employed this is usually a 1099.
this also the amount of work that
determines your income
then you have a business owner their
income does not depend on active work
this is on the passive side of the
equation if you're a business owner you
get corporate tax breaks as you might
have known
donald trump has reduced the corporate
tax rate from 35
to 21 percent this is how donald trump
was able to write off his debt there's
definitely
tax benefits to being a business owner
and last but not least you have i
which your income does not depend on
active work this is being an investor
your money works for you and if you have
to pay taxes you have to pay
capital gains tax well traditionally
long-term
capital gains tax is way less than
paying ordinary income so that's the
esbi
cash flow quadrant by none other than
robert kiyosaki we'll attach a link
so you can check that out but this is
something to wake you up when it comes
to taxes i remember reading that when i
was like
23 years old being like dude i got no
clue what this guy's talking about
but i need to understand how taxes work
and how i get taxed
on the money i make last but not least
let's talk about state income tax
because everything we've talked about so
far
has been federal federal the government
taxing you federally
on your income now let's talk about
state income tax so there's a difference
between income tax
and federal income tax right state
income tax is different
so depending on where you live you might
have to pay a certain amount of taxes so
i'll give you a quick rundown
of the highest taxed states in america
number one
first and foremost is new york that's
why a lot of people are moving out of
new york right now you got new york
maryland oregon ohio kentucky
minnesota north carolina massachusetts
hawaii
and wisconsin and everyone who has seen
walked in and basically said dude what
are you shooting today i was like oh
taxes are like where's california on
this list
i'm shocked california's on this list
well according to this list
california is number 13 and highest paid
state taxes
something tells me they're on the way up
last but not least what states have
no income tax what states have no income
tax i'll tell you right now there are
nine states nine states new hampshire
tennessee
texas alaska nevada
south dakota washington wyoming and my
home state of florida
so the question is where do you want to
live depending on where you live
depending on what state you're at
depending on your income bracket
is basically how taxes work so that's it
guys that's this episode on taxes now i
know we covered a lot of territory the
history of taxes breaking down different
tax brackets
the highest states we covered a lot of
ground and i hope you appreciate
all the stuff that we covered today i
know that this is not
easy stuff it's pretty complicated stuff
and typically pretty
boring stuff so i hope that i made this
a little fun for you to watch i got to
tell you something
this was not my comfort zone i stepped
out of my comfort zone
to do this episode so i can get smarter
with taxes
and so you can get smarter with taxes
again i'm not a cpa
but i said you know what trump's in the
news there's so much stuff going on with
taxes
let me understand this better so i hope
you understand this better
as well with that being said if you have
not seen my episode
on how to win the interest rate game
check that out right here and if you're
not seeing my episode
on how your money should flow check that
out right here and if you have not
subscribed to valuetainment economics
do so below and give that like button a
smash to help out the algorithm
and last but not least the whole point
is understanding taxes so you can pay
the least
amount of taxes as possible so you
can save that money
all we talk is money